hey friend I've got a hot tip for you if
you know how to do
these then you might be wondering what
you learn next how about
these or
these see I'm pretty sure they'll give
you a new challenge but also deepen the
knowledge you already have so let's find
out
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of pois spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today I'm showing you what comes
next after you learn your ins spin
flowers but before we dive in I want to
give a quick shout out to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Tera light toys spinballs
and Ultra poy for helping make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-b bus friend of the
channel Becca beon thank you so very
much for supporting my channel my work
and my mission let's face it as po
Spinners we love de climb a skill tree
we love learning new things and
expanding our repertoire but when we're
doing this on an ad hoc basis it can get
a little challenging to know where to
take our interests next what other
tricks you Sim simar skills are there a
bunch of variations on what I just
learned to get down now and what other
tricks are related to what I just
learned too friends I have got you
covered what comes next is all about
giving you inspiration for where you
ought to focus your efforts next to get
the maximum benefit out of what you've
just learned by sharing with you three
options to expand the uses of the skills
that you've already Acquired and given
that just last week I uploaded this
tutorial on inpin flowers and it turned
out to be pretty popular I figured it
couldn't hurt to bring this series out
of mothballs and give a little guidance
to those of you who watch that video and
might be looking for your next challenge
and in case you haven't seen it I'll
also link to that video down in the
description as well as up in the cards
but for right now and without further
Ado what comes next after you learn po
inpin flowers starting with option
number one learn all timing and
Direction modes both ways kind of a
basic Choice I'll Grant you but really
if you're looking to take advantage of
the knowledge you've already acquired
learning one in spin flower it's
definitely time to learn all the others
too the benefits of doing this are
pretty incalculable for one thing it
opens up transitions back and forth
between all the flowers and that'll be
pretty awesome knowledge to get down
into muscle memory but also knowing each
flower both directions means that you
can turn with them and that really opens
up freedom of movement and it also has
to be said that learning each flower
gives you more transition options not
just between flowers but also back and
forth between other py tricks as well
thread the needles cork screws extension
and more nothing says smooth and
controlled flow like having all of your
ins spin flowers down okay so if my
first pick was playing it a little safe
I'm hoping to throw at least some of you
for a loop with my second
pick option number two tuck
turns wait what now tuck turns where did
that come from well what if I told you
that all tuck turns are actually ins
spin flowers no seriously let's take our
together same tuck turns that everybody
learns at some point and make one small
tweak I'm going to keep the PO in front
of me the whole time the result it turns
out that we were performing flowers the
whole time we were just wrapping the
petals around our hips and shoulders
which also means that just like in our
last example of learning our inpin
flowers in all timing and Direction
modes we now have tuck turns to learn in
all four modes as well the most popular
options here are clearly the together
same and split opposites tuck turns but
there's also no reason that we can't
learn them in together opposites and
split Time same direction as well turns
out inpin flowers make for a great
bridge into some body tracing a great
opportunity to spice up your spinning
cool so we have taken a look at other
options for inpin flowers as well as
some unexpected tricks related to them
so for my final suggestion for what
comes next after you learn your inpin
flowers we have yeah it's it's anti-spin
flowers let's be real here option number
three anti-spin
flowers so like I could have put a lot
of things on this list like hybrids
transition exercises and many more but
nearly all of them would have first
required learning anti-spin flowers
anyway while anti-spin flowers may feel
radically different from their inpin
cousins half the prerequisite knowledge
is stuff you've already picked up your
arms are trained to move in a variety of
timing and Direction modes already so
all we're doing is teaching them a new
way to interact with the poy as they do
so plus which anti-spin is no longer the
painfully challenging Big Brother of
inpin flowers in a lot of I find I'm
able to teach people anti- spins either
at the same time or even before they're
ins spin flowers the barriers to entry
here have become quite low with better
teaching techniques and once you do get
your anti-spin flowers down a whole
world of possibilities open up not only
are their fun and fascinating
transitions that become available you
can also go down the rabbit hole of
Vulcan Tech gospel and learn the ins and
outs of Po flower transitions in hybrids
it's really stunning just how broad a
range of possibilities open up when you
have down both your ins Spin and
anti-spin flowers and if you like
exploring the possibilities of
transitions using your flowers you're in
luck I'm starting up a new round of live
stream POI classes next week and this
session is going to focus all on flowers
learn all the transition points in and
out of your POI flowers as well as the
best techniques for adding dance and
expressive body movement to them by
signing up for my four-week flowing with
poy flowers class all lessons are
recorded and can be rewatched at your
convenience registration is open now
over at crowdcast doio drexfactor poy
hope to see you in class what were some
of your favorite tricks and techniques
that learning inpin flowers opened up
did I miss a few drop me a comment and
let me know make sure to like share and
subscribe to help other people find this
video and to help my channel
[Music]
grow
this video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd like to extend a warm
thank you to my flow patrons who are
listed on screen right now thank you so
much for supporting my channel my work
and my mission if you're out there
watching this and you enjoyed this video
please consider signing up to help me
make more like it in the future you can
do that by heading over to patreon at
patreon.com drexfactor pooy and signing
up there you can get access to a whole
host of excellent rewards but better
than that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world do check
that out please and thank you and if
you've already gotten your anti-spin
flowers down and you're curious what
comes next after learning those po
tricks I've got a video on that topic
that I'll go ahead and link to down in
the description as well as up on screen
thank you so much for watching make sure
to get out and flow today and I'll see
you with a new video real soon take care
now peace